foreign
check I got another one for you okay
okay it's transparency
okay all right I like all right I like
the concept it's very important
um in a democracy and uh yeah yes yes
yes that's not that's more figurative
invocation of the term normally
established you have a healthy uh media
you know BS yes yes yes yes yes yes
so unless it's behind closed doors then
it's not transparent yes by Design
because it would have National Security
implications they tell us yeah they call
that that's then um then that's when I'm
I'm like really no is it really am I is
your government protecting you right are
you really protecting me are you really
going Men In Black on me or no they
don't want you to know about the aliens
right right okay I just want a general
discussion about transparency because I
think it's fascinating Okay so
if we're in the same room and I see you
uh you know there's a day when said well
there's nothing there so that's why I
can see you except of course there's air
there of course all right
so it's not that there's nothing between
me and you blocking The View
air is blocking the view except that air
happens to be transparent
to the light that we are detecting
okay okay
it is transparent
air all right so now when we build
domiciles homes and whatever you want to
be able to look outside
you could just cut a hole in the wall
and look outside because air is
transparent
but we don't we want to protect
ourselves from the elements
so instead of having air in the opening
on the side of the world that is itself
transparent
to visible light
okay and that's what we call Windows yes
which are variations on sio2 silicon
dioxide okay silicons
unless you grew up you know
not privileged you know and then it was
then it was it was polyethylene
I think you you didn't have to be
privileged to have glass windows I think
that's not oh excuse me Mr rich guy
excuse me
excuse me black Trump
what's that go I'm so poor I don't have
a pot to piss in or a window
that's the one I heard all right so so
that's transparent right okay the Sun
is peaks in the energy that it sends to
Earth it peaks in the red orange yellow
green blue violet part of the spectrum
the visible light part of the spectrum
and within that it Peaks right at the
green yellow boundary okay so the sun
gives more green yellow light than any
other kind of light that's out there all
right that's part of why we say the sun
is yellow except it's also giving just
as much green and no one says the sun is
green
right so but it's the mixture of all of
those gives us the color of the sun
which is basically white all right my
point is
how does sunlight reach us
here on Earth
because the atmosphere is transparent
okay but occasionally a cloud Moves In
clouds are not transparent to visible
light so they block the sun right this
sounds all very basic and simple agreed
I'm I'm right now I'm with you on every
step
okay so now now what else is transparent
all right you are in your home
you have glass in the windows you have
walls I do like you have a roof and a
floor
okay that's true and then your cell
phone rings
well is your cell phone using visible
light no no it isn't no it's using
microwaves right I have a really crappy
carrier so my cell phone doesn't it's
not wrecking it's not working okay so
the microwaves the microwaves have no
hesitation penetrating your walls with
or without the window okay you could you
could use your cell phone in a
windowless bathroom
so two microwaves which are part of the
electromagnetic spectrum
your home is transparent nice
so if you had microwave vision
your home basically disappears you might
see the the door frames you know
depending on how it's framed out you
might see some metal wiring and things
but overall the house disappears
in the same way when you look out a
window you're not looking at glass
the glass disappears to you right and
and you know it does when people walk
into that stuff in in stores actually
I'm looking out my window right now and
I'm like maybe I need to clean these
because this glass is not disappearing
this is straight up safety glass that
I'm looking at right now it's safe to go
no one is walking through this class
so uh yeah so you know what safety glass
is it's glass that breaks into a zillion
tiny pieces I didn't know that I thought
it was glass that didn't break like you
know basically no no no well that could
be a variant on safety glass but in cars
where they say safety glass right when
the car windshield breaks it completely
shatters into tiny little bits of glass
so the question is how does it make me
feel safe
no no but you ask how deep into you can
a tiny piece of glass go
like the depth of the tiny piece of
glass
whereas if the windshield broke in these
huge shards yeah it could penetrate you
and and get into your heart break your
jugular or whatever the worst you need
is a bag of Band-Aids at the end of the
broken glass of safety glass that's all
it's designed to be completely shattered
all right all right that version of that
variety of safety glass is designed for
that that's it all right so but that's
not what we're talking about we're
talking about the fact that two
microwaves your home is transparent
right your home is also transparent to
largely to radio waves now if you're old
school
some of our listeners are old school and
know what radio is Radio is you'd go
into a tunnel
if you were listening to FM the FM
signal would drop out if you're
listening to am it would stay yes okay
am has greater penetration through the
surroundings of tunnels than FM does
all right so it's all a matter of who is
transparent to whom now
let's say you let's tune our eyes to so
you have uh there's red orange yellow
green blue violet below red we have
infrared
okay and Below infrared we had
microwaves so microwaves get through
stuff okay right but microwaves have a
hard time getting through metal
okay the metal interacts with them it
prevents that I learned that the hard
way in my oven but
it's a story in your microwave oven you
have a metal so this the door is made of
glass right okay microwave goes right
through the glass
but it's not pure it's not only glass
your door has this mesh on the inside
right okay and the wavelength of
microwaves is like a few millimeters up
to maybe a couple of centimeters in that
zone wow so that mesh has holes
that are smaller than the size of the
microwave so they can't come through so
I can see in but the waves bounce back
you can see him because you're not
you're not using microwaves to see
anything which goes through the holes
right but then the visual is way smaller
than those holes so I'm not getting a
radiator because the waves can't get
through the holes so they bounce back
into the microwave back into the
microwave correct okay correct so now
let's look at infrared which is
brilliant
what a simple yes
science and engineering this is what we
these are the foundations of
civilization right I can't believe I got
a sign seven what
oh no now let's go to infrared
so now let's look around us in infrared
you'll see things that are infrared is a
good measure of temperature because
things will glow if they're glow we know
this from Predator things we know it
from Predator from Predator yes
that's how we know about infrared okay
we didn't pay attention in school but
then we saw the alien monster up in the
tree and it was making that gurgling
sound like
and it was looking at Arnold
Schwarzenegger
you know and uh and we saw him you know
damn you remember the sound effects too
damn man if if it bleeds we can kill it
right which is brilliant yeah but that's
it that's that's a that's the most
brilliant line in the movie so he was
wrong
[Music]
if it bleeds we can nuke it yes exactly
because that's so that's how it died it
nuked itself so it didn't bleed to death
he blew up after they're going jungle
okay because he lost first and the
pressure is a bad loser let me just tell
you that right now
I ain't never lost no game and been like
that I'm nuke in this whole place
this whole place is going on mushroom
clouds and all
screw you humans that has nothing to do
with what I'm trying to say I know I'm
sorry
you're going off on a predator tangent
all right so but you're correct Predator
has Vision uh has infrared vision by the
way so too did Terminator interestingly
also played by that same guy
so all right so infrared I look around
and I see things glowing then I try to
look out the window
and I can't
it's opaque
it is opaque
and you can test this yourself you ready
okay so put someone on one side of the
window and have them turn on a
flashlight and the other side they can
see the flashlight now have someone turn
on a like a glowing oh like a like an
iron like an iron you know a red high
and have him go on the other side of the
window and ask if you feel the heat of
the iron
you do not feel it at all oh that's so
cool because glass is like an insulator
glass prevents the transmission of heat
yes wow okay
so glass transparent glass is opaque to
infrared light light yes yes nice
okay well let's keep going
um how about uh radio waves but like
radio waves are what you get when you go
beyond microwaves they have excellent
penetration depth through everything
basically that's why it works as
communication otherwise you say I'll
call you at 300 310 but get out in the
street and face the radio tower when
we're talking that if you know that's
not what it is wherever you are we can
find you and we can communicate with you
right so so I'm just trying to have
people broadly think
about the fact that when you say
something is transparent
technically you should be specifying
transparent for what wavelength of light
right for what wavelength correct by the
way you know what else is opaque to Wood
glass blocks UV
glass blocks UV glass out of the box
will absorb 97 percent of UV that hits
it and I've done this experiment using
in a laboratory okay out of the box it's
a UV filter when you buy special
sunglasses that say UV board
protections right they're getting you
from the 90s if it's they're made of
glass they'd get you from the 97 it gets
for free up to like 99 okay wow now
there are physicists when they were
testing atomic bombs and they had high
energy radiation there what they would
do is they would dip behind the
windshield of the jeep that drove them
out there oh it would still be bright
visually bright but the high energy
radiation would be blocked by the
transparent glass so glass blocks
infrared on one side of the visible
spectrum and
ultraviolet on the other side of the
Spectrum which is beyond Violet and it
transmits
by definition what we call visible light
and that's what makes glass quite a
fascinating thing
in our in our in our culture and in our
civilization so that's that's why Wonder
Woman never gets a tan
um
riding around
the glass ship
a plane
I forgot about that place it's some
flying thing it's a flying thing but
it's a parent's flying thing yeah
because we call it a plane but the truth
is we we can't see it so we don't know
what it is to be honest right right
because it's invisible so in Harry
Potter they had the invisibility cloak
oh that thing is cool
okay so here's what you do is since you
are in the way between me and what's
behind you okay I can't all of a sudden
make you transparent but you if you but
we we have research such as what they
had in Harry Potter whereas you put on
this invisibility cloak and what happens
is the light from behind you
hits the back of your cloak and is
channeled around the front and then
comes straight back out from the front
of you wow this is a very complicated
Optical Pathways that the light has to
take if
that
then my pathway goes to your chest
around you and to the wall behind you
and I don't even know you're standing
there because I don't know the light
took that Securities route because it
comes straight to my eye wow so I can
make you transparent if the light behind
you is brought around to the front of
you this was also shown in a James Bond
film I forgot which he can make his his
Aston Martin disappear but really you're
just bending the light to the front so
you're bending the light around it
that's correct correct and it means you
should still be able to shoot it
the bullet's not gonna say hey where'd
the car go I don't know what to do
that's funny the bullet still has its
trajectory and it's going to be right to
the Target
um so just that was just a little I
thought I'd spend a couple of minutes
talking about transparency I liked it
yes and of course the the uh counselors
and and therapists have have you have up
taken the word all right are you
transparent with your spouse are you
transparent okay and that's somebody
who's trying to that's somebody who's
trying to end your marriage and let you
know right
if I tell you to be transparent with
your spouse they are trying to end your
marriage is what they're doing every
good marriage is built on a healthy lie
and people should know this it's just
Chuck's advice
it's a healthy lie that that saves every
marriage okay okay
thank you Chuck for your expert uh
24 years and I would never I tell her
that she looks just like the day I met
her that is what I tell her girl you
look just like the day I've met you oh
look at
you look just like the day I met yeah
now I am lying through my teeth
I'm lying is what I'm doing
this is everything you see that Geico
commercial did you see the Geico
commercial with Abraham Lincoln and Mary
Todd Lincoln and
um you know it's an old video footage
because we didn't have
video back then right in Lincoln's day
so but it's it's it's old D old time
right you know black and white all right
sepia tone right so he says
um was uh
Lincoln lie that was that was the setup
right right and so Abe Lincoln is just
there in his office and Mary Todd come
in comes in with a new dress and she
said does this make me look fat
Abe Lincoln says oh uh
he doesn't answer and she runs out of
the room
see honesty that was the time to lie is
that what you're saying
that's it
this has been yet another star talk
explainer this one on the transparency
of all that's around us Neil deGrasse
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
Chuck your personal comedian can I call
him
my personal comedian yeah I was gonna
say not theirs nothing until next time
keep looking up
foreign
[Music]